- Dealing with climate disruption
is eliminating the use of fossil fuels
which is a source of
this tremendous wealth.
It's like telling somebody
who had a plantation
in 1855 that, "Fine. You're
going to walk away from this,
"and you're not going to have a dime
"from all these slaves that
"you've developed over these years."
So how do you get around that?
This is not easy.
You saw how it ended in
1861, two, three, four, five.
Didn't end very well.
I don't think we can
afford that kind of ending
for the climate crisis.
And yet the challenge is
as great if not greater.
In this case, we've enslaved
nature rather than people.
- [May] And people,
who are part of nature.
- Indeed.
So we have both going, right?
Okay, that's fair.
So how do we do this?
May, you're, you uh-
- Well I think it's the right analogy.
Frankly.
I think in terms of this question
about "wrecking the economy,"
which is the number one retort
when we make this
argument about divestment
or about changing the energy system.
There's plenty of people who
are not climate activist by trade,
but who are, run the Bank of England,
or are Michael Bloomberg,
who will make the argument that actually
the way around this problem
is that we're losing money
right now by not acting.
And that in fact the transition off
of fossil fuels is the way to avoid some
of the worst economic impacts
we're sleep walking our way into.
This whole idea of stranded
assets risk in a carbon bubble.
It's exactly what you
were just describing.
That why people are
stopping investing in coal.
It's because they realize at some point
that is not going to be profitable,
and they should get out of it now.
So it really depends on
some of those factors,
but I would end by saying
it is a moral issue also.
The financial argument is compelling,
and it is changing the economy,
and that's important, but it's also wrong.
It's wrong to be causing this problem.
And people's lives are at stake.
And that's why the analogy is right.
An enormous disruption was created,
but it was the right
cause at the right time.
Just like this is.